the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or to view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
so I'm going to try to run through
things pretty quickly and if you don't
have any sort of video experience or
still photography experience a lot of
this will sound foreign to you if you do
some of it will be very familiar but but
either way if what i'm saying is
confusing because of the sort of the
density of it i would just sort of
encourage you not to be too freaked out
because the takeaways are actually
fairly simple I mean it's kind of like
again there's a lot of complicated
technology and a lot of complicated
technique but the base is pretty pretty
simple and what I'm going to do part of
what I want to do today is just expose
you to some concepts and terms that you
actually may not have to really fully
grasp or have like mastery of in order
to make your video but it's worth it to
at least kind of know what they are I
think yeah I'll know but i do want to
i'm going to i'm very cognizant of not
wanting to spend more than like 30
minutes so can you tell me if I'm if I'm
you know like maybe tend to to just kind
of give me a wave or something you know
condensed even more okay so visual
language I mean there's a sort of a
question you know what do we mean by
visual language because it's kind of a
contradiction in terms sometimes we
think of language and the visual as
being at odds with each other you know
we have text we have speech and we talk
about oh well we got to make it visual
so you know what is a visual language it
goes back to something that I talked
about in the first class and I in some
ways what I'm going to do today is try
to build on some of those things that I
sort of raced through them we have all
of these plastic elements of film that
we can manipulate and today I'm going to
focus on a handful of them in particular
camera because the camera is kind of the
you know the speech device that allows
us to speak in this visual language and
Elizabeth made a really interesting
point or quoted a very interesting kind
of way of thinking about it which was
all of us understand this language
better than any generation that's ever
lived because we just have consumed at
our entire lives but that doesn't mean
we can speak it and you know
understanding it is a great for Stepan
speaking it but you really have to kind
of unpack it and think about it
consciously in order to be able to kind
of reproduce it or change it and make it
what you want it to be anyway so I'm
going to race through some of these
fairly quickly focus mostly on camera
and I'm going to dispense with sound
right away because I just want to say
about sound don't dispense with it right
away don't do what I'm doing it is super
super important getting as I think I
mentioned this the other day getting
good sound is absolutely critical and
sometimes sound can be more important
than pitch and all the stuff I'm going
to talk about it's also sort of the
boring part sometimes you know well you
know is the microphone close enough to
me I don't know you know who's listening
to me and I okay good all right because
it's really important because if you
don't hear me and or even if you can
sort of hear me but it's a camera like
and it's six feet away there's a huge
barrier between your audience and your
material so do not skimp on sound you
know the environmental sound is
important it's important to be in a
quiet room it's important to have a good
mic placement it's important not to have
a signal be too soft or too loud listen
with your ears and then you know
creatively you can do so much with sound
too with music and sound effects but I
don't really have time to talk about
that stuff so yeah yeah okay good I just
want to sort of make the pitch to not
forget about sound in all of this but
let's go let's go on and talk about
about camera and I don't know if you
know there any theater people here or
people who've done theater but I want to
start with this concept of the
proscenium you know film and video film
at least has been around for over 100
years 125 years or something like that
you know the sort of first Edison
experiments or the lumiere brothers in
France I think it was they know the late
19th century and for the first 20 years
of the technology the way people kind of
accessed it or thought about it and the
kinds of things that people did were
based on theater and because that of
course is thousands of years old it's
you know in a theater you sit in an
audience and there's a frame which is
the proscenium and then stuff happens in
the
in the in the frame and a lot of the you
know plastic elements that we ran
through the other day are very very
relevant you've got lighting you've got
staging you've got frame you know sort
of placement of people you've got
costumes you've got sound effects music
even all sorts of things very very
similar but it all happens in this kind
of static frame right there in the
middle of your field of view and it was
really literally about 20 years before
people started going Oh with a camera we
can do something a little bit different
than that the for the first films and
these were wildly popular films I mean
it's already a big industry very quickly
it turned into a major major
entertainment and communication industry
but people would set up a camera and
then people would do their thing in
front of the camera and then they would
project the thing and people would be
like wow this is really cool this is
like theater except you know we can ship
watch it again and again and this is
very relevant to educational video
because that is essentially what a
lecture is the lecture is a proscenium a
presentation of material and the
question which you're asking yourselves
in this class is okay we got that we get
that you know when we watch media
whether it's online or on television or
in a theater obviously we have
progressed way beyond that visually in
terms of visual language and the tools
and techniques that we use to do that
are the things that you need to do in
order to become conversant in this you
know quote unquote visual language not
just a consumer of it but a speaker of
it so I'm going to go over something
that that I it's sort of like a
convenient bucket to to put things into
and I you know it's also easy to
remember when I think about camera I
think about the 4 f's and you know some
of them are F because I want I make them
BF just as easier I so f stop or
exposure and if you know anything about
photography or film f-stop is the
aperture of the camera lens and you can
let more or less light in but
what I mean by that actually is not just
the f-stop or the exposure of the lens
but how you control the light it could
be lighting it could be the shutter
speed if there are a million different
ways of controlling the exposure of what
you're filming a second thing is focus
first thing about focus is it's a good
idea to have it it's kind of one of
those non-negotiable things you really
do want something to be in focus in your
frame sometimes you might not but it's
better to do that in post you know
always make sure something's in focus I
you may be working with cameras that
take care of this for you both of these
the exposure and the focus i'm not sure
is that true okay that you guys will be
working with you want necessarily it's
not a yeah an element that you can
control necessarily on the device or you
can control that only by fooling the
device which is something you could
might want to do if you get more sort of
comfortable with it um did you focus on
these cameras you just literally touch
the touch
in focus and exposure we're going to
have to tweak with the external lighting
yeah yeah 99 times out of 100 is pretty
straightforward and you know the auto
systems on these on newer cameras are
really pretty good about it so I'm not
going to spend a lot of time dwelling on
that but they're kind of non-negotiable
you know you want to get a good exposure
and you want to get something in focus
and nine times out of ten that something
is someone's face the person who you're
filming not always but usually third one
is focal length and that is basically
you know how many millimeters you are
shooting at from wide angle to tell a
photo and you know your camera you're
not going to be changing lenses on the
chemical you can zoom in and out focal
length is not the same thing as wide
shot or close up people often think that
think that that's true but it's not you
can go completely wide angle on a camera
and then walk up I can walk right up to
Elizabeth and get a get a close-up and
similarly I can go all the way telephoto
and walk back 50 feet and get a wide
shot but they have very very different
kinds of resonances and feelings and
emotions so when i'll try to talk a
little bit about that in a minute you
might want to do everything at a very
long lens you might want to do
everything at a wide angle it will mean
something different it will feel
different framing this is the big one
and this is kind of like the catch-all
that I throw all of this sort of real
you know real thinking about visual
language into it's not just framing as I
talked about the other day like oh gee
what you know do I Center somebody to
put them on the right on the left it's
the entire structure of your your video
how am I going to shoot this where am I
going to put the camera how is it going
to edit together is the camera going to
move is it not going to move so framing
is the big one and that's mostly what
I'm going to talk about today what in
that broader context quickly so exposure
just to get this out of the way this is
what an aperture looks like in the lens
again it's automated for you big number
means not a lot of like getting through
little number means a lot of lights
getting through this affects the
exposure in a way that I'm not going to
get into but basically you have a lot
more depth of field
a lot more will be in focus the smaller
the whole because the the photons that
get through are more more directed their
less scattered and we talked about this
just just as a sort of an example of
plastic elements of film so these are
two stills from science out loud videos
I think we saw a little bit of the
exoplanets video the other day I don't
know if you've seen this one on plants
okay um what I thought was really
interesting about these two frames is if
I was storyboarding this you know what
would I do what would I draw I would
draw something like this right medium
shot you know presenting a camera but
that doesn't capture anything about what
is you know compelling about these shots
it's all the other stuff you know here
we are launching into space deep space
to look at planets and here we are
bright welcoming you know the world of
plants it's kind of an obvious point but
but this tells us nothing about that
unless you then add a lot of other
information and that's kind of what
storyboarding is about it's not just
about kind of what does my shot look
like but it's about we know what is all
this stuff in the shot that's going to
really make it compelling and it's the
time it's really a great moment to start
thinking about you know locations field
of flowers Wow yeah I guess I need a
field of flowers where am I going to get
that or what if everything was black you
know what if it's a black screen and how
are we going to shoot that lighting I
don't know if that's even an option here
I just I'm not going to go into it but
we have a like
doing lighting but come talk to either
one of us there
the only yeah the only thing I'm going
to say about lighting is is it's kind of
like being a doctor like first do no
harm if you bring the ring lights out
and you don't know kind of what you're
doing and you aren't sort of trained on
the kit you can break the kit you can
hurt yourself or someone else or you can
ruin your video on the other hand it's
really really an important tool and when
something that you know you can't shoot
certain kinds of things without some
kind of lighting I'm not necessarily
recommending that you try to use
artificial lights or you know become a
lighting expert it's a little beyond the
scope but if it's if there's something
like you know to go back to this example
you have to light to get to get it look
like that that some kind of lightning
has to be done you know maybe not film
lighting or video lighting but some kind
of like you know lighting setup has to
be created in order to get to look like
that yeah I'm sorry oh you can improve
it but you have to you have to begin
with something that that's been filmed
with that intention except that you want
to do in your video you can come talk to
me about it
you can't achieve some of these things
with Jake your props like I've done I'm
not proud that's okay oh you don't even
know genki till you've like you have
been on some of the shoots I thought Oh
totally yeah you don't need a super
fancy left kick no absolutely and and
that's exactly what I'm about to get
into to do like that sort of like dark
room thing I mean you don't need a fancy
video light kit but you do need to light
the person and yeah it could be a desk
lamp with paper over it to sort of
smooth it out you know to diffuse the
light but you will need to do something
it's not going to just magically happen
and that's the point of this lighting
doesn't necessarily mean a video light
kit it means being aware of the
environment and the available light that
you're shooting in and taking that into
account either be either by manipulating
thats thing like a light kit or by
taking advantage of the best light in
the world which is the Sun I so you know
for example if I was shooting in this
room and I didn't have any lights I
might love that background out there but
shooting somebody in front of that
window is not going to be possible if I
want to get the background because by
the time I expose for the person's face
the background is going to be completely
blown out and if I expose for the
background the person is silhouetted so
unless I want that look I really can't
happen unless I bring in lights and it
would actually take quite a bit of
lighting fluorescence you know you can
do a lot with fluorescent overheads I
mean the difference between me standing
here look at my face here and look at my
face you know here where do you want
your person to stand and you can
manipulate that kind of thing even in a
lab or a classroom or some other setting
you can make choices based on the
available light or the the ambient light
that will help you and you know the
other thing to think about you know in
terms of exposure going back to exposure
is what do I want to be properly exposed
in that face you know floating in
blackness the face is properly exposed
everything else is very very dark that
the face is properly
goes in the flower shot the whole thing
is properly exposed this mutt is you
know it's more even lighting there's
some nice modeling on the face but but
the whole point of that is that you want
to see the environment you want to see
the flowers you want to have this very
vibrant bright scene so being very
sensitive to the light that's available
is part of lighting it's not necessarily
like setting up a bunch of light stands
and you know video lights and you know
spending two hours when you should have
been shooting your your scene because
it'd be also be very time consuming
quick tip online yeah most of you will
probably be filming indoors and relying
a lot like the only caveat to that is
people here but for me like the glasses
is a big shadow poor glaring the lens
yeah for that like maybe a desk lamp
that also shown on your face from a
little bit below to hide their shadows
particularly as Elizabeth mentioned if
you defuse that light with like some
kind of tissue or something in front of
it because one thing about lighting you
know the first do no harm when you're
lighting faces harsh direct light
whether it's sunlight or desk lamps or
video lights you know are very
unflattering so that's absolutely a
great a great tip but I think it's
always a good idea to sort of try to
defuse it you know you can put like if
it's if it's not a hot light you can
even put like a tissue or paper towel a
white paper towel in front of it and it
will give this very nice soft light but
if you're shooting something indoors and
you just feel like the person
probably because it's like an overhead
left at casa
so just experiment with like a desk or
something yeah and I'm not going to go
into focus too much because again I know
you're going to be working with
autofocus but just to say you know make
sure that what you want to be in focus
is in focus you there are all sorts of
things you can do to mess with the depth
of field which is like how much of the
plane of your image is in focus so if if
you have a very if you're very wide open
if there's not a lot of light then
suddenly you have very shallow focus
which means if you were filming me my
face might be in focus in the background
would be out of focus if you're if you
are stopping way way down because
there's a ton of light suddenly it's a
very deep focus situation where
everything's in focus and that may or
may not be a good thing you may not want
more focus you know there's something
very nice about just what you want to be
in focus in and everything else being
out of focus because that makes people's
eyes go to what they want what you want
them to see it also creates depth in the
frame so this is I'm that's here I am so
this is under if you've seen this
science out loud video engineering trash
into treasure I won't show it but it's
got a really nice opening which uses
depth of field really effectively so
this is a person talking about the
creation of charcoal and in the
foreground are the props and she's out
of focus and it's kind of
counterintuitive because your presenter
is out of focus and the props are in
focus in the foreground but it's
actually quite engaging and interesting
and then what they do and this is
something that you will have a hard time
doing if you are just doing Auto focuses
they shift the focus to reveal her and
that's a reveal that's something we
talked about the other day you know
revealing things is part of the visual
language that you want to think about
whether it's bite with that cut with an
edit a change of the angle a pan a
camera move revealing your next thing is
really is just kind of a key visual
element so here it's like you know the
the burning I forget what kind of corn
yeah the burning corn husks come into
frame and then the charcoal comes into
frame and then the focus shifts and you
reveal the person who's been talking to
you it's cool it's quite it's a nice
little opening
yeah I exactly one way to my sort of
cricket is if you stand really far in
front of your background that's like the
closest what you're going to get that
blurry background right in fact so if
you wanted to film in this classroom for
instance and you didn't want the stuff
on that report to be really visible you
would have Chris move up like all the
way up to maybe where David is at peace
and then she right and so that's what
this is so again we you have a zoom lens
if you go all the way wide on the lens
you have much deeper focus than if you
zoom all the way in so if I walk up and
shoot Elizabeth with a very wide angle
everything behind it will be in focus if
I go way back there and I get the same
kind of close up of Elizabeth with a
longer apart part of the zoom everything
behind will be out of focus which might
be better if we don't care about the
background and if it's or if it's messy
I mean I've often been in labs it just
look horrible and the best way to handle
that is to zoom you know zoom way in go
way back and have the background be way
out of focus or you can as Elizabeth
mention you can bring the person forward
so that there's a lot of distance
between the person and the background so
so focus focal length all of these
things relate to each other and again
we're going to move a little quickly but
yeah yep no I'm doing fine i think i
think i'm doing okay you know this is an
extreme wide-angle you can see how deep
the focus is it just it's it's in you
know infinity and this is a telephoto so
it's a close-up but even the leaf behind
the bird is is out of focus just a word
about zooms so there are two kinds of
zoom and there's one kind of danger or
well two kinds of danger actually
optical zoom which is the you know if
you zoom in and out with the zoom
control on your camera that is the way
you change the focal length then there's
digital zoom which is usually on these
cameras I assume these are like this if
you go past a certain point you're not
changing the lens anymore you're just
zooming in on the image itself digital
the problem with that is that your
resolution goes down immediately it
looks really bad it starts to pixelate
and just fall apart so I would recommend
that you not use the digital zoom I mean
it's kind of those situations you know
people say oh well one kind of use it
I'm like well when the UFO is landing
and Killian Court and you know you're
just too far away to get the shot
definitely use the digital zoom but you
know if you don't if you have time to do
something different or plan a little
differently then then you know stick
with the optical and also realize that
you can zoom in on a frame in post when
you're editing so it's generally better
to just capture something wider so say
you want to do like a traditional
interview set up and you're not sure how
close you should be in into your subject
go ahead and air on this side of zooming
out as much as possible you can always
play with how much you zoom when you're
editing later and the other thing about
zooming I mean maybe this is just a
matter of personal preference but
generally I don't like it when I see the
camera zooming in live time I prefer
seeing just a clean cut from a wider
angle to the to the zooming and that's
the other part of the danger for sure
yeah yep that's um zooms in general I
mean unless you're doing it because you
know what you're doing and you know all
these rules are made to be broken that's
something I should should mention right
up front they're often kind of the lazy
persons way of doing something and in
general I would even go so far as to say
even if you're not planning to show the
zoom if you're you know if I was again
filming Elizabeth and I wanted to get a
wide shot and I so I shoot her here and
then I want to close up and i zoom in on
Elizabeth and I get the close-up there's
something kind of unpleased about going
from a wide angle shot to a zoomed-in
telephoto shot of somebody the more sort
of smart way to do it is to pick a focal
length that makes Elizabeth look great
and is what gives you what you want and
then move the camera in don't change the
don't change the focal length of the
lens when you change the size of the
shot so you know maybe I end up on a
medium shot you know I mean in terms of
the focal length and then when I want to
get the close-up I pick up the camera
in and get the close-up and that's going
to cut better it's going to look better
it's going to feel betters going to feel
like just more controlled and like you
sort of knew what you were doing so
zooms very useful dangerous as well
alright so back to the proscenium I just
wanted to say a little bit about framing
you know what shots you actually need to
tell your story well the way you figure
that out is exactly the way you do with
animation or anything else you do a
storyboard and this is the storyboard I
did a few years ago for a narrative
scene but you'll see it contains a lot
of the things that we've talked about in
this class you know who's our main
character this kid how do we know that
well the next shot is a point of view of
what this person is seeing there's a
moving shot up and you know the next
thing that you see is his grandfather's
reveal you see what they're looking at
and only then do you actually see a wide
shot which is a home-built airplane
being pushed down a field so there this
is kind of you know this visual
storytelling a very simple thing like
who's our who's our character what do
they see who's around them and then
revealing the whole scene could have
been done completely differently this
could have been the first shot could
have been here like let's establish the
scene let's see all the people then
let's kind of you know cut in and see
our main character or you know maybe
maybe it's revealed later there's no
right or wrong answer here but the point
is is that you know you what you want to
do is think through your scene just as
you do with animation that whole process
that Josh took you through is completely
relevant to absolutely everything that
you're going to shoot you know just a
few notes about what different shots do
wide shots establish the location the
environment the spatial relationships
they had production value I mean you
know I don't know about you but if I
could go to the top of this bridge I
would shoot this shot I wouldn't not
because this is awesome you know and
that's happened I've seen that happen
people get an incredible location an
incredible view and they don't get the
shot that shows what where they were you
know that's what we call by production
value you know similarly I think this is
an awesome picture this was actually
taken in 1911
this is a this is a Russian
pre-revolution Russian nobleman in a
tiny village in Russian it was taken in
1911 it's an amazing picture but you
know I would feel like I missed a huge
amount if it was just his face I you
know you learned so much about the
environment you learned so much about
the person by having a wide shot I mean
if I was if this was a video I might
want to also have a close-up when I
started to hear about him and learn
about what who he was but you know boy
this is great like you know how would
you how could you miss that so again
showing environments getting production
value establishing characters and
relationships relationships in space
closer shots well they kind of bring you
into someone's world they reveal details
closer shots of a face closer shots of
what the person is looking at if you're
explaining something obviously really
good close shots that show the angle you
know show from a good angle what you're
trying to describe are very very
important so again it's kind of obvious
but just make sure to get those as well
you want to get the wide shot but you
know if you're actually describing a
process that's like a physical process
that somebody's doing make sure you
document it well and that you don't
shoot it from the angle where the
person's hand is covering the key thing
you know just look at your look at your
frame and see if you're actually
communicating what you want to
communicate you know moving shots in
those kinds of moving shots you can Pan
the camera on a tripod you can fall you
know you can walk with the camera you
can move on a dolly they have all sorts
of great uses they are they reveal story
beats you know if again to keep picking
on Elizabeth if I want to introduce
Elizabeth and I dolly or pan over to
Elizabeth people want to know what the
end of that shots going to be what am I
going to see oh this person who's a
character that I'm supposed to pay
attention to or you can follow a person
it creates a very strong point of view
if someone's walking and talking and
you're following them then we pay
attention to that person because the
camera is picking them out of the
background
to pay attention to so that's part of
this visual language similarly we could
do a point of view of that person's
walking and then we're sending into
their world so you know kind of a
classic situation is someone's walking
we're following them and then you cut to
the reverse and you see what they see
and now we're in their head so it's
another another great thing and then
there's just kind of you know the
classic one of you know we have reptile
brains that's the same reason we edit
quickly here's a new thing you know
here's an you can either it cut to a new
thing or you can pan or dolly to a new
thing let's see just a quick word about
locations always and you're going to
talk about this too but always scout
your locations it's smart producing
which elizabeth is going to talk about
but it's also very smart creatively I've
been in so many situations where I've
gone to a location you know a few days
in advance and I've completely rewritten
my script based on the location either
because i saw a problem that I wasn't
anticipating like you know a classic
wine is okay well we're going to film
all this stuff at the electron
microscope but there's a column here and
I can't shoot anything from this angle
oh [ __ ] we're really good to find that
out a few days in advance because you
can't move the microscope so what are
you going to do or because the location
is really cool and there's amazing stuff
and you go you get very excited because
there's all sorts of possibilities that
open up that you hadn't you couldn't
have ever imagined just sitting you know
doing your own story board in your room
or writing your script but suddenly
because this place is amazing you see
all sorts of things that you could do so
i always suggest trying to visit your
location one first just kind of
practical scouting reasons like you know
is there i could chainsaw factory next
door you know but to because it can
completely affect your creative vision
and try to do it enough in advance so
that you can incorporate what you learn
so i'm going to just wrap up with us a
couple of words about editing this is
where all of this stuff comes together
and where you find out whether your plan
worked your storyboard your visual
language your script and it's also where
you fix all the things that didn't work
and I guarantee you that plenty of
things will not work there just a word
about pacing be role in transition so
pacing is kind of you know like how much
do i edit and this is kind of the big
question like gee what's the what's the
big thing you know what's the secret
what's my pacing what should it be like
and I don't think there is an answer to
this I mean when I was in film school
20-plus years ago I was being taught by
people who were trained in the 1950s and
people who were trained in the 1950s
will tell you two would tell us well you
really can't edit faster than four
seconds per shot because the human brain
just can't comprehend an image that
lasts shorter than four seconds and I
remember dutifully editing my very first
piece and following that rule and
watching it and going like this sucks
like this is terrible like this is
what's wrong with this this is like
awful and you know it's because four
seconds is a really long time you know
in some cases in a lot of cases in many
cases in most cases and you know and
that has increased is only increased I
mean my idea of a fast edit may be
completely different than your idea of a
fast edit because I'm older I don't know
and there's also the difference between
genres and you think Elizabeth mentioned
this briefly you know television there's
a serve like you know bombard everybody
like you know if you want to show an
establishing shot of a house in a
reality TV show you can't just show one
shot or two shots you have to show eight
shots you know there is 12 frames long
like boom boom boom boom boom with like
drums going just to like you know like
make the reptile brain go oh oh yeah
this is important somehow I don't know
and it gets kind of absurd at a certain
point and it can be over obviously over
editing but the more typical experience
the people who are just starting out
have is that they don't shoot enough not
that they shoot too much you know you
think oh I've got three shots and you
know this is going to cover like 30
seconds on my video but 30 seconds it
can be an eternity and if you don't if
your shots aren't telling a story that
could be pretty skimpy
which brings us to be role I'm going to
talk about that in one second with an
example the other thing though to think
about is transitions like how do I get
from this to that I mean obviously you
can just cut but is there you know is
there an issue like I'm cutting from a
medium shot of Chris talking talking
talking to a medium shot of Elizabeth
talking talking talking that's not
necessarily super compelling you know do
I need some other way of transitioning
do i need a wide shot of the classroom
do I need people listening you know what
other shots so I need to tell my story
into transition from scene to scene the
b-roll I just wanted to mention have you
guys talked about that would that even
means at all okay I was going to show
the this in the PowerPoint but b-roll is
a term that goes back way way back like
80 years ago when people edited on film
the b-roll was the second roll of film
that they would then composite over the
first roll of film and it was all the
stuff that wasn't included in the sort
of main narrative and I'll show you what
I mean in a minute this is a just a
little sip it from a video that we shot
not too long ago with Jeff Hoffman who's
a professor here an arrow Astro former
astronaut and we had done a storyboard
and kind of a script plan so we knew
when he was going to be on camera and
when not the design construction and
operation of aerospace vehicles have
allowed us to leave the surface of the
earth and fly through our planet's
atmosphere and out into space I'm Jeff
Hoffman I'm a professor in the
Department of Arizona anyway um we knew
that he wasn't going to be on camera in
the first part so we were able to cut
between takes we didn't even bother to
you know get it really you know have him
be compelling on camera at that point
but here we knew he would be on camera
so we filmed them that way and the first
string out is just literally putting
together your script in a very linear
way the way you wrote it you know
without any kind of fancy stuff and then
i'll just show you what it looked like
after
I'll just for the first
ten seconds and then i'll be done
1girl all engine running
lift we have a liftoff 32 minutes past
the hour looked up in Apollo 11 have you
ever wondered how lock its work have you
ever looked out of the window of an
airplane and wondered how something so
big and heavy can actually fly have you
ever wondered what happens to the human
body in space or how a space suit keeps
astronauts alive and able to work in the
vacuum of space these topics are all
part of aerospace engineering aerospace
engineering is given humans the freedom
to move in three dimensions the design
construction and operation of aerospace
vehicles have allowed us to leave the
surface of the earth and fly through our
planet's atmosphere and out into space
mission specialist Jeff Hoffman hello
I'm Jeff Hoffman I'm a professor in the
Department of aeronautics and
astronautics at MIT before coming to MIT
I spent 19 years at it out we were able
to shoot with him very very quickly
because we only need we knew what we
needed on camera and we knew that we
were going to be able to cover and fill
and it sort of explained things with
other imagery in this case a lot of it's
obviously archival stuff but it could be
stuff that we shot and later in the
video their stuff that we shot because
it was all the same plan anyway I know
that's quick a lot of stuff thrown at
you but I'm also I'm cognizant of the
time so we can talk about this after
class to a few if you like thanks so
just to give another example of b-roll
be on a more likely level for you guys
because I assume you won't be going out
into outer space this is a great
and for Anastasia's video they all come
from you notice that she's not talking
over any of it we put the be rollin
because we needed to give the video a
little bit of space to breathe otherwise
it would have been just her talking
constantly and saying facts so we wanted
to help with the pacing of the video
which was what Chris was talking about
so that's why we shot funeral so if
you're if you're especially you Paul
because I imagine you're going to shoot
some stuff maybe with the boats or like
you have access to certain equipment and
whoever you're filming with you're not
only going to shoot Paul but I would
also spend some time like maybe just
doing a pan of your environment shooting
some of the equipment that's around it
may not be super relevant to what you're
talking about exactly in those moments
but you can always have that footage to
intersperse like we did here if that
makes sense and and as Chris was saying
you're not always going to shoot b roll
yourself NASA I guess is what you guys
used and all their stuff is there not
copyrighted or license so you can use
that footage there's a lot of a lot of
photos and pictures that you can look up
I'm going to talk a little bit more
about music that you can use and I can
hit graphics as well next week during
the editing lecture but there are
resources out there if you want certain
footage that you just can't shoot
yourself